This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖尔斯。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在别处根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得怎么做的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一身铠甲。这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。侦探大军花了很长时间才揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个陌生的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们
all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Thanks for tuning in.
都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听播客《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目。感谢收听。
Thanks for tagging along. If you have been following me on Instagram, following my travels recently, you'll know that I decided to take two months off and just really like go on a holiday. somewhat of a holiday, some of it was for work, but mainly for like, kind of like leisure and pleasure and, you know, just to kind of see new things. I feel like a lot of us are at this moment making up for the travel that we couldn't do during the pandemic, especially if you're in your 20s or even your 30s. There are so many people right now who I think are feeling almost like so many of their initial plans for what they wanted in their 20s. were interrupted by COVID, by the pandemic. You know, naturally, people were super sick, people were dying,
感谢一路相伴。如果你一直在关注我的Instagram，关注我最近的旅行，你就会知道我决定请假两个月，真正去度个假。算是一次度假吧，其中一部分是为了工作，但主要是为了休闲和娱乐，你知道的，就当是去看看新鲜事物。我觉得我们很多人现在都在弥补大流行期间无法进行的旅行，特别是如果你正处于二十多岁甚至三十多岁。现在有很多人，我觉得他们甚至觉得自己二十多岁时对未来的很多最初规划，都被新冠疫情、被大流行给打乱了。你知道，很自然地，人们病得很重，人们在死去，
we didn't know what was going on, everything was kind of shut down. And the thing is, is that each of us individually had a plan during that time that may be involved some form of travel, and that plan was restricted, it was interrupted. And so now we're kind of like making up for that time that we missed and like flocking overseas in our thousands. myself included, I went to the US for four weeks with my sister and then Japan for five weeks. The first week with my family, which honestly, traveling with family has its own unique psychology. That is for another time, another day.
我们不知道发生了什么，一切都处于封锁状态。问题是，我们每个人在那段时间里都有一个计划，可能涉及某种形式的旅行，而那个计划受到了限制，被打断了。所以现在我们有点像是在弥补错过的时间，成千上万的人涌向海外。包括我自己，我和我姐姐去了美国四周，然后去了日本五周。第一周和我的家人在一起，说实话，和家人一起旅行有它独特的心理学。那是另一时间、另一天的话题。
But I then did the last remaining four weeks with my boyfriend. Well, that was the intention. But we actually ended up leaving a week early. and the main reason for that was because of travel burnout and travel fatigue, which I didn't know was possible. I had never heard of this happening. And travel burnout I have since learned essentially occurs when you have been traveling too hard for too long. You become incredibly tired, anxious, indecisive. You maybe resort to sleeping a lot more than you like to, avoiding parts of a city crying a lot more. And a raise.
但接下来剩下的四周我和我男朋友一起度过。嗯，原本是这么打算的。但我们实际上提前一周回来了，主要原因是因为旅行精疲力竭和旅行疲劳，我以前不知道这竟然是有可能的。我从未听说过这种事情发生。我后来了解到，旅行疲劳本质上是当你旅行强度太大、时间太长时发生的。你会变得异常疲惫、焦虑、优柔寡断。你可能会开始比平时睡得更多，避开城市的某些部分，哭得更多。还有各种各样。
of different symptoms. And I think what happened was that I pushed myself too hard. It was by far the longest trip I have ever done, almost double what I had done before. And I was hit with basically what I can only describe as just intense, mental, emotional, physical exhaustion. And I hit like a fork in the road. You know, stay and struggle and maybe not enjoy this or leave and maybe resent my decision, but at least I'll be back home in my routine where I can kind of switch off for a few days before getting back to work. That was another component of it. We were like, we're going to go on this like two month trip and then we're going to go back to work two days later. You know, it was just like very, I think for someone who loves routine and for someone
不同的症状。我想发生的事情是我把自己逼得太紧了。这绝对是我做过的最长的旅行，几乎是我以前经历的两倍。我基本上受到了我只能将其描述为强烈的情感、精神和身体上的筋疲力竭的打击。我遇到了一个十字路口。你知道的，是留下来苦苦挣扎，可能无法享受这一切，还是离开，也许会对我的决定感到后悔，但至少我会回到家里的日常生活中，在那里我可以在回到工作岗位之前关闭大脑休息几天。那是另一个组成部分。我们当时想，我们要去进行这个为期两个月的旅行，然后两天后就要回去工作。你知道，这真的很……我觉得对于一个热爱日常规律的人来说，对于一个
who is such a planner and who really needs rest and who needs time for kind of like a mental reset, that it was too much. And we decided to leave early. Obviously, that is a very serious conclusion that we reached. But I think it really got to the point where because I had ignored so many of the signs and early indicators of travel burnout, there really wasn't another solution. I just let so many small grievances build up. I didn't take time to rest. I wanted to just really soak as much of the trip up as possible. And I just didn't have the travel experience to know. know that you could overdo it, right? Like, holidays and travel are always something in our minds to look forward to.
如此注重规划、真正需要休息、需要时间进行精神重置的人来说，这太过分了。于是我们决定提前离开。很显然，这是一个非常严重的决定。但我觉得事情真的到了这个地步，因为我忽视了太多旅行疲劳的迹象和早期表现，真的没有别的解决办法了。我只是任由许多小委屈积少成多。我没有花时间休息。我只想尽可能多地吸收旅行中的一切。而且我没有足够的旅行经验去知道。知道你是会过度劳碌的，对吧？假期和旅行在我们心中总是让人期待的事情。
But that kind of means that we forget, like, the key principle of everything in life, which is that balance is key and even too much of a good thing can turn bad. And it's honestly given me such a newfound appreciation for the people who can travel for months, even years at a time, living out of a backpack in hostels. One of my best friends, Gracie, is like one of those restless roving spirits. And it just gave me like a complete new respect for what she does. How much mental energy it requires. Travel burnout got me really good and I want to talk about it.
但这某种程度上意味着我们忘记了生活中一切事物的核心原则，那就是平衡是关键，即使是再好的事情，如果过头了也会变成坏事。说实话，这让我对那些可以一连几个月甚至几年在外面旅行、背着背包住在青旅里的人产生了一种全新的人。我的好朋友格蕾西就是那种不安分的流浪灵魂之一。这让我对她所做的事情肃然起敬。这需要多少精神能量啊。旅行疲劳狠狠地击垮了我，我想谈谈这件事。
It felt like at the time that my fatigue was like the ultimate ingratitude. You know, it was like feeling. weary of this experience felt so almost like shameful and like embarrassing. I'm seeing a world that people dream about on like a once in a lifetime trip, but I'm also just so tired that I cannot even get out of bed. I cannot even enjoy it. Everything almost feels like a form of punishment. And I think with any experience like that, any emotional experience that like seems a little bit contradictory or confusing. There's always going to be some interesting psychology and kind of perspective on it. There's always going to be an explanation. Of course, I went looking for it and I was not disappointed by,
当时感觉我的疲劳就像是一种极致的不知感恩。你知道的，那种对这种经历感到厌倦的感觉，几乎让人感到羞耻和尴尬。我正在看人们梦寐以求的世界，这是一次一生难忘的旅行，但我却累得甚至无法起床。我甚至无法享受它。一切几乎都变成了一种惩罚。我认为对于任何这样的经历，任何看起来有点矛盾或令人困惑的情感体验，总会有一些有趣的心理学和视角来解释。总会有个解释的。当然，我去寻找了，我并没有感到失望，
I think, what some of the science reveals about our deeper human need and how that kind of translates into why we have this experience of being burnt out from too much of a good thing. So I say we get into it. Firstly, I want to say one thing loud and clear before we begin. Travel is an absolute, without a doubt, privilege. It is also just genuinely really good for us. Like I know in this episode we're going to be talking a lot more about the negative side of it. But really, if you can travel, if you have the ability, there is no reason why you shouldn't. It has been shown to improve so much about our lives and our self-development.
我想，科学揭示了我们更深层次的人类需求，以及这如何转化为为什么我们会有这种因“物极必反”而精疲力竭的体验。所以我说我们开始吧。首先，在开始之前，我想大声而明确地讲一件事。旅行绝对是一个不容置疑的特权。它对我们来说也确实非常棒。我知道在本期节目中我们将更多地讨论它的消极面。但事实上，如果你能去旅行，如果你有这个能力，没有任何理由不去。事实证明，它在很大程度上改善了我们的生活和自我发展。
our resilience, our confidence, our happiness. It even lessens anxiety to an extent. It's a really big list of the benefits. It's obviously been lauded and celebrated for years. It's like a really amazing thing. It creates adventures. It creates new memories. I don't think I need to go on.
我们的复原力、我们的自信、我们的快乐。它甚至能在一定程度上减轻焦虑。好处的清单真的很长。它显然多年来一直受到赞誉和庆祝。这就像是一件非常了不起的事情。它创造了冒险。它创造了新的记忆。我想我不需要再多说了。
There's no denying those things, right? And I think it goes without saying that I am incredibly grateful just for the opportunity to be able to consider travel as part of my life. So many people don't have that option. And maybe you're thinking, okay, we're talking about travel burnout when, you know, there are millions of people suffering in the world. And my biggest problem is that I have too much travel. I have thought about that extensively, trust me. But I also believe that that acknowledgement of the innate privilege of travel and the subsequent guilt for not valuing it entirely, even when you're exhausted, actually contributes to a deeper level of fatigue and a deeper level of
这些都是不可否认的，对吧？我想不言而喻的是，我非常感谢有机会能够将旅行视为我生活的一部分。很多人并没有这种选择。也许你会想，好吧，我们在这里谈论旅行疲劳，而世界上还有数百万人正在受苦受难。而我最大的问题却是我旅行太多了。我对此进行了广泛的思考，相信我。但我也相信，这种对旅行先天特权的承认，以及由于未能完全珍视它而产生的负罪感（即使在你筋疲力尽的时候），实际上会导致更深层次的疲劳和更深层次的
I think just overall exhaustion because you don't want to take it for granted. So you force yourself to endure a lot of situations and stress and experiences that actually maybe aren't that glamorous or aren't that good for you. Secondly, when I was thinking about this thing of like, is travel burnout even worth talking about considering that there are so many bigger problems, I think minimizing emotions by saying people have it worse or different does nobody. any good. We know that. And when you're in the moment, in that moment of like, of really carrying some big emotions, someone else might have it worse. They probably do. But that doesn't in any way
我认为这纯粹是总体上的筋疲力竭，因为你不想把它视为理所当然。所以你强迫自己忍受许多其实并没有那么迷人、或者对你并没有那么好的情况、压力和经历。其次，当我思考“考虑到有那么多更大的问题，旅行疲劳真的值得讨论吗”这个问题时，我认为通过说“别人过得更惨或有所不同”来将情绪最小化，对任何人都没有好处。我们都知道这一点。当你在那个当下，在那种真正承载着巨大情绪的时刻，别人可能过得更糟。他们很可能确实如此。但这并不能以任何方式
less than your discomfort. It doesn't change your situation. It can still be subjectively hard. So we are going to move forward with just an acknowledgement that what we're talking about is based on something we are incredibly lucky to be able to do, but there are still hard moments. There are still hard points that impact us psychologically and mentally. So travel, going overseas, going on a vacation, embarking on like this once-in-a-lifetime adventure, seeing different cultures, environments, new people, new scenery. I think in our day and age is one of those like quintessential experiences that many of us really want to have in our 20s. For many of us, it's part of that dream, the dream, the idea of the
减轻你的不适。它不会改变你的现状。它在主观上依然是艰难的。所以我们要继续前行，只是承认我们所讨论的事情是基于我们非常幸运能够做到的事情，但其中仍然有艰难的时刻。仍然有在心理和精神上对我们产生影响的艰难节点。所以旅行，去海外，去度假，开始一场千载难逢的冒险，领略不同的文化、环境、新的人群、新的风景。我想在我们这个时代，这是许多人真的想在二十多岁时拥有的典型体验之一。对我们许多人来说，这是那个梦想的一部分，那个梦想，那种
glamour that we perceive this decade as having, you know, it's this time to travel. It's this time to experience the world before life gets too big and too busy. And there's children and there's mortgages and there's obligations. Our 20s are quite frankly, I talk about this a lot, sold to us as a decade of freedom of adventure. And a core component of that is getting out there, seeing as many places as you can. And I think that comes in a bunch of different forms, a bunch of different versions of this dream, whether that is going on a gap year. That's a huge one studying abroad or like the big trip is what I call it, like six months or more of backpacking, something of the sort. And I think there's a few main reasons why these kinds of
我们认为这个十年所具有的魅力，你知道，这是去旅行的时刻。这是在生活变得太宏大、太忙碌，有了孩子、房贷和各种责任之前体验世界的时刻。说实话，我们的二十多岁——我经常谈到这一点——被当作一个充满自由和冒险的十年兜售给我们。而其中核心的一个部分就是走出去，尽可能多地看不同的地方。我想这有各种不同的形式，有这种梦想的各种不同版本，无论是去过间隔年。这是一个很大的选项，去海外留学，或者像我所说的“大旅行”，比如背包旅行六个月或更长时间，诸如此类。我认为有几个主要原因使得这些类型的
kinds of grand adventures have really been romanticized. Firstly, a big part of it comes back to our parents. We think about the stories that they told us of their travels when they were our age. And we want that for ourselves. It looks really amazing. It looks really cool. It looks really identity forming. Or if we had parents or families who didn't necessarily have the opportunity to do that, we kind of want to break that chain. We want to be the one who shows, I don't know, the world that we can do it. Like who says that it doesn't matter if my family didn't grow up doing this. Like I still have, I still have a right to have this experience.
宏大冒险真正被浪漫化了。首先，很大一部分原因要追溯到我们的父母。我们想到了他们给我们讲述的他们在我们这个年纪旅行的故事。我们也希望为自己拥有那样的生活。它看起来真的很棒。它看起来真的很酷。它看起来真的很具有塑造身份的作用。或者如果我们父母或家庭不一定有机会做到这一点，我们就会想要打破这种束缚。我们想成为那个向世界展示我们能做到这一点的人。比如谁说即使我的家庭没有在这样的环境中长大也没有关系？我依然有，我依然有权拥有这种体验。
We also see a lot of content these days about travel all over social media, friends, influences, celebrities. All of it is incredibly glamorized and it looks amazing. And I think that's what we want for ourselves. But any time we base our expectations on someone else's experiences, I think we are unfortunately going to fall short of what we desire. I don't need to tell you that, but a lot of what we see online is far from the full truth. And with the stories that are passed down from parents and friends, they are told from the point
如今我们在社交媒体上也能看到很多关于旅行的内容，朋友、网红、名人。所有这些都被极大地浪漫化了，看起来棒极了。我想这就是我们为自己所渴望的。但每当我们把期望建立在别人的经历之上时，我想我们不幸地往往会达不到我们所渴望的。我不需要告诉你这一点，但我们在网上看到的很多东西远非全部真相。至于从父母和朋友那里流传下来的故事，它们都是从
of hindsight. And hindsight always makes everything look so much more beautiful. the stories are always going to be more golden because we only really remember the good things. So what we are basing our expectations on, when we go traveling, when we embark on this huge trip of a lifetime or whatever it is that you're planning or doing, we base our expectations on a false narrative at times. And when reality is different, I think we can be really disappointed. And because it is so romanticized, we have so many expectations, not just in terms of the quality of the trip, that's one part of it, but also the quantity of experiences and how much
事后诸葛亮的角度讲述的。事后诸葛亮总是让一切看起来更加美好。这些故事总是会显得更加美好，因为我们真正记住的只有美好的事物。所以当我们去旅行，当我们开始这趟千载难逢的宏大旅行，或者无论你在计划或做什么时，我们所依据的期望有时是一个虚假的叙事。当现实有所不同时，我想我们会感到非常失望。正因为它是如此浪漫化，我们才会有如此多的期望，不仅是对旅行质量的期望，那只是其中一部分，还有对经历的数量以及我们应该
we should be doing. We want to do everything. We want to make sure it's worth it. It's also because travel is expensive, you know, like I have this problem where I can never justify rest days when I'm traveling because I've flown so far, paid for such an expensive ticket, especially being from Australia, that it would be a waste to not finish every day with like 20 things ticked off my bucket list. But I think the downside of that is twofold. We think that this is going to make our trip better. It can actually have the inverse effect. When you overplan a trip, I think you miss some of the best moments that are like hidden in the times and the places where you take it easy. Like the serendipity of taking a day to just
做多少事情的期望。我们想做所有事情。我们想确保这不虚此行。这也是因为旅行很贵，你知道的，我有这样一个毛病，当我在旅行时，我永远无法为休息日找到合理的解释，因为我飞了那么远，买了一张如此昂贵的机票，特别是作为一个澳大利亚人，如果每天结束时没有在愿望清单上勾选掉20个项目，那就太浪费了。但我认为这样做的负面影响是双重的。我们认为这会使我们的旅行更好。它实际上可能会产生相反的效果。当你把旅行计划得太满时，我认为你会错过一些最美好的时刻，那些隐藏在你放慢脚步的时间和地点里的时刻。比如花一天时间像当地人一样
walk the city like a local. One of my favorite days when we were in Curator was honestly when we were just like, we don't want to go to another temple. Like, we don't want to stand in another queue of thousands of people, thousands of tourists. So we just explored. We just wanted. We had nowhere to be. We had nowhere to go. We didn't use maps. And we saw the most beautiful, beautiful things. We found the most beautiful restaurants. And I think we would have missed that if we had stuck to the schedule. If we had let ourselves, be really, I think, held up by the fact that we needed to do all the things that everyone was recommending us. I think secondly, though, you also exhaust yourself to the point where you cannot
漫步城市的奇遇。我们在曲阜时，我最喜欢的一天老实说就是我们觉得，“我们不想再去另一座寺庙了。”——“我们不想再排队和成千上万的人、成千上万的游客挤在一起了。”所以我们只是去探索。我们只是去闲逛。我们哪儿也不用去。我们哪里也不用去。我们不用地图。我们看到了最美丽、最美丽的风景。我们找到了最美丽的餐馆。我想如果我们一直按着行程表走，我们就会错过这一切。如果我们让自己真的被那种必须完成每个人都向我推荐的所有事情的想法所束缚的话。其次，我认为，你也会让自己精疲力竭，以至于你无法
even enjoy the experience anymore because you are doing too much and you are mentally drained. And then you feel guilty for not enjoying the experience because you have drained yourself from doing things every day. But that's the paradox, right? Because the more you do, the more exhaust. you are, the less you want to do, the more guilty you feel, the more you feel you need to do. Like, it's a whole cycle where because we feel so much privilege around being able to travel, because it is such a glamorous experience because it is sold to us as being this like life-defying, like identity-forming, incredible experience. Like if we're not getting everything, every possible morsel out of it, we're doing it wrong.
再享受这段经历，因为你做的事情太多了，精神上已经筋疲力尽了。然后你会因为没有享受这段经历而感到内疚，因为你每天都在做各种事情，把自己搞得精疲力竭。但这就是悖论所在，对吧？因为你做得越多，你越筋疲力竭，你就越不想做，你感到的内疚就越多，你就会觉得你需要做更多的事情。你看，这是一个完整的循环，因为我们对能够旅行感到无比的特权，因为它是一种如此迷人的体验，因为它被兜售给我们，说这是一次颠覆生命、塑造身份、不可思议的体验——如果我们没有从中榨取一切、每一个可能的微小成果，我们就做错了。
And I think right there we have highlighted probably one of the main reasons. since we experience travel burnout. Quite simply, you are doing too much. For whatever reason, maybe you only have a short amount of time in each location. Maybe it is that guilt we were speaking about. You're with a big group of people who just want to cram everything in. Whatever it is, you will hit a mental wall. And you'll probably hit a physical and an emotional wall pretty soon afterwards. Here is why that happens. Travel is so different to our daily kind of status quo. In your daily life, you would not be doing as much as you do whilst you're on holiday. I actually was thinking about this and I was talking about it with a friend. You probably do a
我想就在这里，我们强调了我们经历旅行疲劳的其中一个主要原因。很简单，你做得太多了。不管出于什么原因，也许你在每个地方停留的时间都很短。也许那就是我们一直在谈论的内疚感。你和一大群只想把行程塞满的人在一起。无论是什么原因，你都会撞上一堵精神之墙。而且你可能很快就会撞上一堵身体和情感之墙。这就是为什么会发生这种情况。旅行与我们的日常现状截然不同。在你的日常生活中，你不会做像你在度假时那样多的事情。我其实一直在思考这个问题，我和一个朋友也聊过。你可能只会做
maximum of three things. You wake up, you have breakfast, you go to work, you come home. Maybe you work out. Maybe you see friends. You go to bed. That's about five days of a week if you're working full time, right? And then on weekends, you might do a little bit more, but it's only two days of a week. So you have time to recover. Then when we are transported into kind of like our travel versions of ourselves, we are hitting multiple tourist attractions. We are shopping. We are walking 20,000 steps a day. We are eating new food, meeting new people. People who might not speak the same language as us. We are learning a new city, a new environment, jumping from this place to that. And then you are jet lag onto that. And things go wrong.
最多三件事。你醒来，吃早餐，去上班，回家。也许你锻炼。也许你见朋友。你上床睡觉。如果你全职工作的话，一周大约有五天是这样的，对吧？然后到了周末，你可能会多做一点，但也只是一周里的两天。所以你有时间恢复。然后，当我们被传送到我们旅行中的自我版本时，我们要去打卡多个旅游景点。我们购物。我们一天走两万步。我们吃新的食物，见新的人。这些人可能不会说和我们一样的语言。我们要适应一座新的城市、一个新的环境，从一个地方跳到另一个地方。然后你还要应对时差。事情出了差错。
Then at home, you would have time to deal with. If your wallet got stolen, you got a nasty flu, you would know what to do. You would know what medications to buy. You would go to the doctor. You have a safe space, your home, to come home to and rest. And we don't have that when we're traveling. Everything is kind of uprooted. You are, like, turning the dial of your life from, like, 90% to, like, 150%.
而在家里，你会有时间去处理。如果你的钱包被偷了，你得了讨厌的流感，你会知道该怎么做。你知道该买什么药。你会去看医生。你有一个安全的地方，你的家，可以回家休息。但当我们旅行时，我们没有这些。一切都被连根拔起了。你就像是，把生活旋钮从90%调到了150%。
like you were just turning it all up. And it's really interesting because one of the only real papers written about travel burnout that is in the world, it explored that exact thing. When we are away from home, our sense of self-efficacy is naturally lowered. So self-efficacy is this concept in psychology that basically refers to our belief in our ability to solve problems and our ability to overcome challenges. If you have high self-epicacy, you have a strong belief in your ability to kind of exert control over your behaviors, your choices, your emotions, your environment.
就像你把一切都调大了一样。这真的很有趣，因为世界上仅有的一篇关于旅行疲劳的真正论文，探讨的正是这一点。当我们离开家时，我们的自我效能感自然会降低。所以自我效能感是心理学中的一个概念，基本上指的是我们对自己解决问题能力的信念以及我们克服挑战的能力。如果你有很高的自我效能感，你就会坚信自己有能力对自己的行为、选择、情绪和环境施加控制。
You feel mentally capable of dealing with things. And that self-efficacy is bolstered by familiarity, by repetition, by practice, by confidence. But when we are away from home and the structure that it provides, that ability to solve problems is lowered. once again because everything is so new to us. And I think that it is that novelty and all those new experiences that also becomes emotionally taxing after a while. Each of us has an inbuilt limit around what we can tolerate,
你觉得自己在精神上有能力应对事情。这种自我效能感是通过熟悉感、重复、练习和自信来支持的。但当我们离开家以及家所提供的结构时，那种解决问题的能力就会降低。再次强调，因为一切对我们来说都是崭新的。而且我认为正是这种新鲜感和所有这些新的经历，在一段时间后也会变得在情感上令人筋疲力竭。我们每个人对所能承受的事物都有一个内置的极限，
how much change we can tolerate, how much novelty, how much activity. It's different for everyone, but everyone has a limit here. And after a certain time, maybe it's after a certain time, maybe it's after three weeks, maybe it's after two months, six months, whatever it is. We are hardwired to crave home and to crave what we call creature comforts. There's been some really interesting research on this concept of a creature comfort. And basically one article, it was written like almost 10 years ago, what it explored was this kind of the safety that is provided by home.
我们能忍受多少改变，多少新鲜感，多少活动。每个人都不同，但每个人在这里都有一个极限。在一段时间之后，也许是在一段时间之后，也许是在三周之后，也许是在两个月、六个月之后，无论是什么时候。我们的基因决定了我们会渴望家，渴望我们所谓的物质舒适。关于“物质舒适”这个概念，有一些非常有趣的研究。基本上有一篇文章，大约是10年前写的，它探讨的是家所提供的这种安全性，
and it found that humans naturally need a space that is familiar to them. They are soothed by an environment that feels safe and normal. And at some stage, we will want to return to that domestic environment for even a few days because in that environment, there is nothing new, there is nothing scary, there is nothing to be alert to, everything is comfortable. and some people can suppress that urge, but it's still going to be there. The desire for routine, for familiarity, for security, that is always going to be something that is kind of contained in our DNA as humans.
它发现人类自然需要一个对他们来说熟悉的空间。他们被一个感觉安全和正常的环境所抚慰。在某个阶段，我们会想要回到那个国内环境中去，哪怕只是几天，因为在这个环境中，没有什么新鲜的，没有什么可怕的，没有什么需要警惕的，一切都是舒适的。有些人可以压抑这种冲动，但它仍然会在那里。对日常生活、熟悉感、安全感的渴望，这永远是作为人类融入我们DNA的东西。
The call of home is kind of going to get louder. I also found this quite interesting there, because when I was looking into this, there are some people who sometimes just don't feel that way, as extremely rare as they are. If you've ever seen the film into the wild, I would greatly recommend. Great. It's amazing. But the main character, Chris, is actually a really good example of this. Some people, I don't know whether they were born, whether they were made to be like almost
家的呼唤会变得越来越大。我也觉得这挺有意思的，因为自我进行调查以来，有些人有时就是没有这种感觉，尽管他们极其罕见。如果你看过电影《荒野生存》，我强烈推荐。好。太棒了。但主角克里斯其实就是一个很好的例子。有些人，我不知道他们是生来如此，还是被塑造成几乎像
nomads. They don't need a place to call home, but they are such rare individuals. And I think something I always say, and it doesn't just relate to travel burnout or travel or whatever, is that you can't force yourself into a version of you that belongs to someone else. So there are people out there who can live in nomadic, crazy, like adventurous lifestyle, never needing to have a place to call home, always on the road. And you might like the idea of that, but it doesn't necessarily mean that you are that person. I think that it can still be incredibly lonely.
游牧民一样的人。他们不需要一个被称为家的地方，但他们是如此罕见的人。我想我总是说的一句话，它不仅与旅行疲劳、旅行或任何事情有关，那就是你不能强迫自己成为属于别人的那个版本的你。所以外面有些人可以过着游牧的、疯狂的、像冒险一样的生活，永远不需要有一个被称为家的地方，总是在路上。你可能会喜欢那种想法，但这并不一定意味着你就是那种人。我认为这依然会感到非常孤独。
And anybody that you talk to who has been traveling for a long time will tell you that it's not picture perfect, like they will have hard days. The second reason, though, that travel burnout will eventually hit kind of anyone who is on a long-term, long-term travel holiday experience is because when we are traveling, our brain is naturally working harder because it is constantly being exposed to so much new stimuli, new smells, new sounds, new scenery, everything. In our normal life, we are used to what is around us in our, in our everyday routine.
任何你交谈过的长期旅行过的人都会告诉你，这并不是完美的，他们会有艰难的日子。然而，旅行疲劳最终会袭击任何进行长期、长期旅行度假经历的人的第二个原因是，当我们旅行时，我们的大脑自然会更努力地工作，因为它不断接触到如此多的新刺激、新气味、新声音、新风景，一切都是新的。在我们的正常生活中，我们习惯了我们日常生活中周围的一切。
And that means that we can use these things called cognitive shortcuts. So these are basically like automatic ways of thinking that we use to make decisions. So it makes it so that when you see something and you need to make a decision around it, you're a lot more efficient because you're accustomed to the environment
这意味着我们可以使用被称为“认知捷径”的东西。这些基本上就像是我们用来做决定的自动化思维方式。所以它使得当你看到某事并且需要围绕它做出决定时，你会更加高效，因为你习惯了环境
in which you are receiving information. I'll give you an example. So think about your commute home from work. I bet you that if you've done that a few times, like you might be at that point where you, you, it doesn't even feel like you know what's happening in your surroundings. It is so automatic. It is so procedural to you. I was talking to a friend and she was like, sometimes I drive home and I literally get home and could not tell you a single thing I saw on the road. It's because your brain can kind of switch off because it's so used to the environment.
你在其中接收信息。我举个例子。想想你下班回家的通勤。我敢打赌，如果你已经那样做了好几次，你可能会处于这样一种状态：你，你甚至不觉得你知道周围发生了什么。它是如此自动化。对你来说它是如此程序化。我跟一个朋友聊天，她说：“有时候我开车回家，我literally（简直）一到家，也说不出我在路上看到的任何一件事情。”这是因为你的大脑可以有点关机，因为它太习惯这个环境了。
Whereas when you are, for example, in a new country and you're trying to drive in a new country or navigate public transport, your brain is so switched on because everything is new. We have to use a lot more of our mental energy in those situations as well, because we cannot rely on the cognitive shortcuts that we use in our day-to-day life. We cannot rely on that repetition and procedural memory, you know, that procedural automatic memory. When you are doing that for days on end, constantly being exposed to so many new things, It is going to be draining and mental energy is exactly like physical energy in that it can become depleted. And when it becomes depleted, you need time to refill that source.
然而，当你例如身处一个新的国家，并试图在一个新的国家开车或乘坐公共交通时，你的大脑是如此高度运转，因为一切都是新的。在这种情况下，我们也必须消耗更多的精神能量，因为我们无法依赖我们在日常生活中使用的认知捷径。我们无法依赖那种重复和程序性记忆，你知道，那种程序性的自动化记忆。当你连续几天都在这样做，不断接触到这么多新鲜事物时，它会耗尽你的精力，而精神能量就像体力一样，是可以耗尽的。当它耗尽时，你需要时间来重新填补这个源泉。
Let's also account at this moment as well for the lack of routine. You are probably not sleeping as much as you do at home. You're not exercising in the same way or as much. You're not eating meals at the same time. You're not even eating the same foods that you normally would. You are not operating on the same scale that you do as home. So we know that routine reduces stress. It lessens anxiety.
此时此刻，我们还要考虑到缺乏规律。你可能没有像在家时那样睡得那么多。你没有以同样的方式或同样多的量进行锻炼。你没有在同一时间吃饭。你甚至没有吃你平时常吃的食物。你的运作规模和你在家里时不一样。所以我们知道规律能减少压力。它能减轻焦虑。
Without it, you know, chaos can feel like fun for a while, but you're definitely going to crave that normalcy that we've talked about again and again and again. You're going to crave things that feel familiar. You know, honestly, I was so excited to get home and just like eat vegetables and go into the office and like wake up at a normal time. There was honestly a point when we were in Tokyo where I went to a convenience store and I bought and ate a whole bag of cabbage. I just ate it like on the street because I was like I just need to eat something that I'm used to. It didn't mean that I wasn't enjoying all those other experiences. And it's just that I feel like
没有它，你知道，混乱感可能会让人觉得有趣一阵子，但你绝对会再次、再次、再次渴望我们一直在谈论的那种常态。你会渴望那些感觉熟悉的事物。老实说，我在东京的时候太兴奋了，只想回家吃蔬菜，去办公室，在正常的时间醒来。老实说，我们在东京的时候有一次，我去了一家便利店，买了一整袋卷心菜并把它吃光了。我甚至直接在大街上吃，因为我觉得我只需要吃一些我习惯的东西。这并不意味着我没有在享受所有那些其他的经历。这只是我觉得
I'm like a broken record here, but you do need a sense of stability. No human can operate as nomadic as we think they can. And often I think we think of our holiday as an escape from the routine, you know, escape from like the monotony of daily life. But there are some elements that we shouldn't neglect, especially making time to decompress or do things that you would do at home to bring some sense of stability. And that stability also allows us to return to mental homeostasis. So a mental place of balance, of security. One final experience I think is also important to touch on, especially for my long-term travelers out there, my gapier babies maybe, is homesickness.
我在这里就像个碎碎念的复读机，但你确实需要一种稳定感。没有任何人能像我们想象的那样过着游牧般的生活。而且很多时候，我们认为假期是对日常生活的逃避，你知道的，就是逃避日复一日的单调生活。但有些元素是我们不应该忽视的，尤其是留出时间来放松减压，或者做一些你在家里会做的事，以找回某种稳定感。这种稳定感也让我们能够回归心理稳态。也就是一个平静、安全的精神港湾。我认为还有一个最终的体验也很重要，特别是对于我那些长期旅行的听众、也许还有那些在间隔年（gap year）的小伙伴们，那就是思乡之情。
Like, this is such a huge factor when we talk about travel fatigue. So homesickness, I don't even feel like I need to give you a definition of what this feels like, because if I asked you to close your eyes and think about what homesickness felt like, I think all of us would be having a very similar feeling. It's that longing in your chest. is what the Greeks actually called a nostalgic reaction. It comes from a place of love and attachment, the same way that grief does as well,
你看，当我们谈论旅行疲劳时，这是一个巨大的影响因素。所以思乡之情，我觉得我甚至不需要去定义它是什么感觉，因为如果我让你闭上眼睛，去想想想家是什么感觉，我想我们所有人都会有非常相似的感受。那是你胸口的一种渴望。这正是希腊人所说的怀旧反应。它源于爱和依恋，就像悲伤一样，
but it also causes a disruption in our present environment. If we let it infiltrate too much of our everyday experiences, if we let it take us away from like living in the moment whilst we're somewhere new. And there is a lot of research behind why we experience that kind of profound longing for the place where we belong. Home and belonging and community is really precious. It's like, I think one of the main things that humans need to not just survive, but to thrive. And when we don't have that, and we also have a low perceived control over our environment, when we are constantly being exposed to novel new things, it can actually manifest in quite a few physical somatic symptoms.
但它也会扰乱我们眼下的环境。如果我们让它过多地渗透到我们的日常体验中，如果我们让它让我们无法活在当下的新环境中。而且，为什么我们会对我们所属的地方产生那种强烈的渴望，这背后的研究非常多。家、归属感和社区真的是非常珍贵的。我想，这是人类不仅为了生存，更是为了蓬勃发展所需的最主要因素之一。当我们没有这些，而且我们对周围环境的感知控制力又很低时，当我们不断接触到各种新鲜事物时，它实际上会表现出相当多的身体躯体症状。
So they see this a lot actually in research with young children at boarding. schools who have all of these like ailments and illnesses of an unknown origin. Soar stomachs, fatigue, irritability, constant crying, they complain about like aches and pains. And obviously when you have a bunch of children who are suddenly ill and in pain, it's something that you want to look into. And what they found was that a lot of these kids actually have no, most of them have no physical signs of pain or trauma. It's actually their emotions having a physiological impact. on our bodies. It is our emotions trying to communicate with us. Like something is wrong, something is missing, something isn't right. It's almost like a homing beacon. Like it's telling us like
所以在针对寄宿学校幼儿的研究中，他们经常看到这种现象，这些孩子有着各种病因不明的病痛。胃痛、疲劳、易怒、经常哭泣，他们抱怨各种酸痛。显然，当有一群孩子突然生病和痛苦时，这是你需要去调查的事情。而他们发现的是，这些孩子中的许多人实际上并没有、大多数人没有任何身体上的疼痛或创伤迹象。实际上是他们的情绪在对我们的身体产生生理影响。这是我们的情绪在试图与我们沟通。就像有什么不对劲，有什么东西缺失了，有什么事情不顺利。这几乎就像是一个归航信标。就像它在告诉我们
go back to what we know. This is causing discomfort because emotionally I'm not feeling stable. And that creates a physical instability as well. So I think those are the major contributing factors to travel burnout. Number one, obviously, sometimes you're just doing too much and you're going to deplete your physical, mental, emotional resources. Number two is the novelty of these new experiences actually takes a lot more, it is a lot more taxing for our brains because we cannot use those cognitive shortcuts that we normally use at home. And finally, it's homesickness. It's a craving for what they call our creature comforts. I think that is all. fine and good to understand, but a deeper question you probably have, if you are listening to this
回到我们熟悉的事物中去。这会引起不适，因为从情感上讲，我并没有感到稳定。这也造成了身体上的不稳定。所以，我认为这些是导致旅行倦怠的主要因素。第一，很显然，有时你只是做了太多事情，你会耗尽你的体力、精力和情感资源。第二，这些新体验的新奇感实际上需要付出更多的代价，对我们的大脑来说要劳累得多，因为我们无法使用我们在家里经常使用的那些认知捷径。最后，是思乡之情。这是对他们所谓的家常舒适感的渴望。我想，理解这些都很好，
episode, is, what do I do about it? What can I do? I'm on my dream trip. I'm on my gap here. I want to go home, but I don't want to go home. Like, I just feel this need. What is there to do? What is the solution? Well, I want to talk about that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there are also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
但如果你在听这一集，你可能会有一个更深层的问题，那就是，我该怎么办？我能做什么？我正在进行我梦想中的旅行。我正在过我的间隔年。我想回家，但又不想回家。就像，我只是有这种需求。到底能做什么？解决方案是什么？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我想谈谈这个以及更多内容。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及建立恢复力的科学，
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是会引起炎症的。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上所恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方上的 TWO Percent。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们自己采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我要成为他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他将得到他应得的。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？你可以去“Look Back at It”播客里找答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会聚焦一个话题，剖析事情的来龙去脉，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一期请来马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大家海阔天空地聊了聊80年代的快克。坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不只是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都能聊一聊快克，不过先让大家知道这一点。我是说，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking Tripp Fantine. Ryan Clark, sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核领悟》，我是您的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的正是特里普·范廷。瑞安·克拉克，有时我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。而且这也是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. One of the worst things you can do when I think you're feeling any kind of negative emotion
加入我的新播客《硬核领悟》，我是凯尔·盖恩斯，我们将在节目中就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。当你感到任何负面情绪时，你能做的最糟糕的事情之一
is to shame yourself for it. Obviously, you don't want to be feeling this way. If you had a choice about it, you would not be. Do you know what I mean? Like, I feel like something that I find quite frustrating is when people, shame other people for an emotion that they actually don't have control over, where if they had the solution, if they had the antidote, they would gladly take it. They would gladly move on from this feeling. And I think travel burnout is one of those feelings where we feel a lot of like anger at ourselves almost for not enjoying our trip. But I don't want that to
就是为此而感到羞耻。显然，你并不想有这种感觉。如果你有选择的话，你才不会这样。你知道我的意思吗？比如，我觉得挺让人沮丧的一点是，当人们因为某种情绪而羞耻另一个人时，而这种情绪其实并不是对方能控制的，如果他们有解决办法，如果他们有解药，他们一定会欣然接受。他们一定会欣然摆脱这种感觉。我认为旅行倦怠就是这种感觉之一，我们对自己没有享受旅程感到非常愤怒。但我不想让这种情绪
ruin it for you. I think that whilst you can't control the physical, mental, emotional reaction you're having, you can control your response to it. And I think it is a mindset that you can get out of, that you can recover from. But it is going to take like some actual steps. It is going to take you actually suppressing what your guilt is telling you to do by doing the things that are actually going to help you. I think if we sit too much in the feeling of like, keep trying to keep pushing, trying to push through exhaustion to a point of like, I don't know, catharsis or like to a point of like greater mental clarity. Like, it's actually not going to work. When I was going through this, I actually talked to quite a few friends who are very seasoned travelers.
毁了你的旅行。我认为虽然你无法控制自己身体上、精神上、情感上的反应，但你可以控制自己对这些反应的处理方式。我觉得这是一种你可以摆脱、可以恢复的心态。但这需要采取一些实际的行动。你需要通过做那些真正能帮到你的事情，来压制住内心罪恶感对你所说的话。我觉得如果我们过分沉浸在这种感觉中——一直试图坚持，试图强行克服精疲力竭的状态，直到达到某种，我不知道，宣泄的程度，或者达到某种更清晰的思维状态。这其实是行不通的。当我经历这段时期时，我其实和好几位经验丰富的旅行者聊过。
The kind of psychological research on this is pretty sparse. It's kind of non-existent, actually. So I'm going off of a lot of anecdotal and observational evidence about like the main things that you should do to get yourself out of this like travel fatigue travel rot the first one every single person said to me was to take a freaking rest day i know it sounds so obvious but just let yourself be you don't have to be a verb all the time you don't have to be doing things all the time you can just relax that's part of the experience like i think every single one of us goes into like a holiday or goes into like a vacation or whatever like with wanting to get something different out of it. None, we cannot get any of the things we want to get out of it if we don't actually give
关于这方面的心理学研究相当少。其实可以说是几乎不存在。所以我参考了很多轶事和观察证据，总结出了一些主要做法，能帮摆脱这种旅行疲劳或旅行倦怠。第一点，每个人都对我说过的，就是放假休息一天！我知道这听起来太显而易见了，但放过自己吧。你不需要每时每刻都像个动词一样不停运转，你不需要每时每刻都在做事，你完全可以放松。这也是体验的一部分。我觉得我们每个人开始一段假期时，或者开始一趟旅行时，都希望能从中获得一些不同的东西。
ourselves time to process the things that we're getting out of it. Do you know what I mean? Like you could have had the most profound life-changing experience yesterday. But if you are forcing yourself to like continue doing new things and like pushing yourself and pushing yourself, like that experience isn't going to get the time it deserves to actually like consolidate and to actually like be. processed. Slowing down, I think, can bring just as much joy as trying to overplan and speed up and seeing everything. It is in those slow moments that I think the most beautiful things happen, the same way that beautiful things happen in our daily lives when we are peaceful, when we are
然而，如果我们不给自己时间去消化我们从中获得的东西，我们就无法真正得到我们想要的任何东西。你知道我的意思吗？比如你昨天可能经历了一次最深刻、最改变人生体验。但如果你强迫自己继续做新鲜的事，不断地逼迫自己，那么这段经历就不会得到它应有的时间去真正沉淀和消化。放慢脚步，我认为，它能带来的快乐丝毫不亚于过度规划、加快节奏和看遍所有景点。正是在那些缓慢的时刻，最美好的事情才会发生，就像美好的事情发生在我们日常生活中一样——当我们感到平静时，当我们
just taking things easy. Like, I really can attest to this fact that you are not going to have a life-changing experience when you're going to like the top 10 tourist destinations of the places you are traveling to. Maybe if you're like, I don't know, going to see like an amazing cathedral and you're like have like a spiritual awakening, maybe. But I would say most of the time, if you are trying so hard to jump from one thing to the next, you actually don't have time to really appreciate what you're seeing, what you're feeling, what you're sensing. So as well as taking a rest day firstly and actually planning them. Someone said this to me. Like, often we like make itineraries and we never in ever like in our itineraries put a rest day in there when it's
放轻松时。我真的可以作证，当你去参观你正在旅行的那些目的地的十大旅游景点时，你并不会有什么改变人生的体验。也许如果你去，我不知道，去看一座惊人的大教堂，然后你有了某种精神觉醒，也许吧。但我敢说，大多数时候，如果你拼命地从一个地方赶往下一个地方，你其实根本没有时间去真正欣赏你所看到的、感受到的和体察到的东西。所以除了第一步要休息一天并实际把它们排进日程。有人曾这么对我说过。比如，我们经常制定行程，却从来不在行程里安排一个休息日，而这其实非常重要。
really important. So obviously do that. Don't have a plan and get out of the tourist areas as well. Those bright lights, those huge crowds, that is stimulus overload. That is information overload. our senses are just totally barbedded with so much content that our brains just cannot manage, it cannot shift through it all. It's honestly like mentally dizzying. So if you're already feeling the effects of a bit of fatigue, one of the best things to do is to, instead of going to all the hotspots, instead of ticking things off like the list to be like, oh yeah, I went to New York and I did this.
所以显然要这么做。不要有计划，离开那些旅游区。那些耀眼的灯光，那些庞大的人群，简直就是刺激过载。那是信息过载。我们的感官完全被塞满了太多的内容，以至于我们的大脑根本应付不过来，无法从中筛选。这老实说让人精神上感到眩晕。所以如果你已经开始感到有些疲惫了，最好的做法之一就是——不要去所有的热门景点，不要像打卡清单一样去完成任务，比如“哦，对，我去了纽约，我做了这个”。
Of course I saw the Rockefeller Center. Of course I saw the Statue of Liberty. Like everyone is doing those things. try and just like explore your neighborhood a little bit more and take some time to actually get into nature this is a big one that i learned when i was traveling if you have listened to our episode on the healing power of nature you will also be well informed that spending time outdoors is a natural anxiety reliever we are consistently seeing findings out of like the ecocyscology field that exposure to natural spaces for just 15, 20 minutes a day really improves
“我当然去过洛克菲勒中心了。我当然看过自由女神像了。”每个人都在做这些事情。尝试去稍微多探索一下你所在的街区，花点时间真正融入大自然。这是我在旅行中学会的重要一点。如果你听过我们关于“大自然治愈力量”的那期节目，你也会很清楚，花时间在户外是天然的焦虑缓解剂。我们从生态心理学领域不断看到的研究结果表明，每天仅仅接触大自然15到20分钟，就能极大地
so much about your mood. So if you're at a point of like exhaustion and you need like a mood booster, yes, rest day is great and nature day is also amazing and intentional nature exposure. Like actually spending a good solid time at the beach, in a park, somewhere beautiful, just with your thoughts, It's not needing to do anything, not needing to go anywhere. I think those moments create such deep mindfulness. It's like a natural meditation. It's an easy meditation to just like kind of like the charm and the beauty of like a natural environment just wash over you. Let like all of your worries and your thoughts and your fatigue kind of like float away with the wind.
对你的情绪影响很大。所以，如果你正处于精疲力竭的阶段，需要一个情绪助推器，是的，休息日很好，自然日也非常棒，还有有意识地接触大自然。就像在海滩上、在公园里、在某个美丽的地方，真正度过一段扎实的时间，只和你的思绪在一起，不需要做任何事，不需要去任何地方。我认为这些时刻创造了如此深度的正念。这就像是一种自然的冥想。这是一种简单的冥想，只需让自然环境的魅力和美丽洗涤你的身心。让所有的忧虑、思绪和疲劳随风飘散。
I think that's really important. The next thing I would say to do, I would say, this is like advice from other people that I'm just like absorbing and used and regurgitating, but create some routine, have like the same wake-up time, try and eat like the same breakfast. It will recreate some of the comfort and the familiarity of home. Make sure that you call friends. It's easy to feel like when you're traveling, you're in like a little bit of like a holiday bubble.
我认为这真的很重要。我要说的下一件事，我想说，这就像是吸收、使用并复述别人的建议，但创造一些常规，有相同的起床时间，尽量吃一样的早餐。这会重现一些家的舒适感和熟悉感。确保你给朋友打电话。当你旅行时，很容易觉得自己置身于一个小小的度假泡沫中。
I find this a lot as well where I'm. like, oh, my friends are probably busy. They're out doing other things. Like, I don't want to bother them. It feels like we're living in two different worlds at the moment. Like, I'm on my holiday. They're at home. They're on their holiday.
我也经常有这种感觉，我想，哦，我的朋友们可能很忙。他们出去做别的事情了。我不去打扰他们。感觉我们此刻生活在两个不同的世界里。就像，我在度假。他们在家里。他们在度假。
Those kinds of things. Actually, you shouldn't go that long without seeking familiar reconnection, whether that's with family or friends. Like, calling someone who you can actually just be a little bit uninhibited with. Obviously, like when you're traveling, especially if you're doing hostels, you might be meeting a lot of new people, but a lot of those people you don't have a deep connection with. They don't know you as well as someone who's known you for a long time.
诸如此类的事情。实际上，你不应该这么长时间不寻求熟悉的重新连接，无论是与家人还是朋友。就像，给一个你可以完全无拘无束地倾诉的人打电话。显然，当你旅行时，特别是如果你住在青旅，你可能会遇到很多新的人，但其中很多人你并没有深厚的连接。他们不如一个认识你很久的人那样了解你。
So make sure that you continue to prioritize those relationships. I think it will also prevent you from feeling like phomo. Sometimes that's a huge part of why we're like, oh my God, I want to go home, is because I feel so disconnected from everyone. And I feel like I'm not getting anything out of this experience anymore, so I may as well be able to make experiences with these people. We can avoid that by not letting those relationships suffer while we're traveling.
所以一定要继续优先考虑这些关系。我认为这也将防止你感到有错失恐惧症（FOMO）。有时这是我们为什么会喊出“天哪，我想回家”的一个重要原因，是因为我感觉与每个人都脱节了。而且我觉得我从这次经历中再也得不到任何东西了，所以我还不如和这些人一起去创造经历。我们可以通过不让这些关系在我们旅行时受到损害来避免这种情况。
And I also think that journaling, I know it's like such a cliche, we're all about mindfulness here. You know, like, what we're really trying to do here is when you're addressing your travel burnout is to get you out of your body, get you out of your mind into like a more clear place, a place of like mental clarity where you can really process your emotions without feeling, guilty without feeling overwhelmed, without feeling like you need to make some like drastic decision. And I think embracing like the small moments of your trip that might not be like completely stand out and like life changing, but still are really beautiful is really good. So I would say buy a journal. Hopefully you've already brought one with you. If you're a loyal listener,
而且我也认为写日记，我知道这听起来是个陈词滥调，我们这里都崇尚正念。你知道，就像，我们在这里真正要做的，当你解决旅行倦怠时，是让你摆脱身体的束缚，摆脱思想的束缚，进入一个更清晰的地方，一个拥有精神清晰度的地方，在那里你真的可以处理你的情绪，而不会感到内疚，不会感到不知所措，不会觉得你需要做出什么激进的决定。而且我认为拥抱你旅行中那些可能不是完全出彩、能改变人生的，但依然非常美好的小时刻，真的是很好的。所以我想说，买一本日志。希望你已经随身带了一本。如果你是一个忠实的听众，
hopefully you have your journal or your like notebook handy. But ask yourself some of these questions. What did you do today that was memorable? What is something that you did today that you wouldn't have done at home? What is part of my day that is a story I will tell in the future? Who did I meet? And what were the kind of stories they were telling me? What was something in my day that just, like, made me smile that sparked joy? I think take yourself out of this big need and expectation that every day of your trip needs to be a huge,
希望你手头有你的日记或笔记本。但问自己一些这样的问题。你今天做了什么令人难忘的事？你今天做了什么是你在家里不会做的事？我一整天中，有哪些部分是我将来会讲的故事？我遇到了谁？他们给我讲的是什么样的故事？我这一天中有什么事情让我微笑，激发了快乐？我认为，不要让自己背负着“旅行的每一天都必须是一个巨大的、颠覆性的、完全彻底改变人生的经历”这种巨大的需求和期望。
upending, entirely transformative experience. you can still find joy in small moments. You can still find joy whilst resting, while stepping away from the schedule, whilst not going to tourist locations. Like, there is so much beauty just in things that are different, even if they're not, like, incredibly profound. So take a step back, let yourself rest, and don't feel guilty because you're not enjoying every single moment.
你依然可以在小时刻中找到快乐。你仍然可以在休息时、在暂时脱离行程时、在不去旅游景点时找到快乐。有很多美好只存在于那些不同的事物中，即使它们并不是那么深奥。所以退后一步，让自己休息，不要因为没有享受每一分每一秒而感到内疚。
You know what I mean? Like, the guilt is what keeps us in our fatigue, in our negative emotions, because we don't, we don't feel like we can address the problem enough to actually do something about it. We feel so shameful about what we're feeling that we don't actually verbalize it or bring it to the surface and examine it and kind of peel it back and open it up and see what we can do about it. I will say one more thing. I obviously on my trip I left early and I was like talking to my boyfriend about it and I remember being like we were in this hotel room and I looked to him and I was like I need to talk to you about something and he was like yes and I was like I need to leave like I was in tears I was like I just really need to leave at this point like this is the best solution for me like honestly
你知道我的意思吗？内疚感才是让我们陷入疲劳和负面情绪的原因，因为我们觉得，我们觉得我们没有足够地去解决问题，从而无法真正采取行动。我们对自己的感受感到如此羞耻，以至于我们没有真正把它说出来或把它带到表面上来审视它，把它剥开，打开它，看看我们能做些什么。我还要说一件事。显然，在我的旅行中，我提前离开了，我和我男友谈过这件事，我记得当时我们在那个酒店房间里，我看着他，我说我需要和你说点事，他说好，我说我需要离开，当时我都哭了，我说我真的需要在此时离开，对我来说这是最好的解决方案，老实说
it wasn't even that we were leaving like right then we stayed like for another two and a half weeks almost, like two weeks. It was just like, I can tell that I'm already so tired now. By the time we finish this trip, I'm going to be absolutely miserable. And I don't want to look back at this experience and not want to come back to this country. I don't want to project the fact that I am tired on anything to do with where we are, anything to do with this experience, like anything to do with you. I just realized I was like, I've made a mistake. I've push myself too hard. And I don't, I like have this saying where it's like you can either waste your money or you can waste your money and your time. And so like a big part of me was like, I've already
甚至都不是说我们立刻就走，我们几乎又多待了两周半，大约两周。我只是觉得，我能看出我现在已经这么累了。等我们结束这次旅行，我一定会痛苦不堪。我不想回首这段经历时，却不想再回到这个国家。我不想把我感到的疲劳投射到我们所在的地方、投射到这次经历、投射到你身上。我只是意识到，我犯了一个错误。我把自己逼得太紧了。我不……我有一种说法，要么你浪费了钱，要么你既浪费了钱又浪费了时间。所以很大一部分我在想，我已经
paid for this ticket. Like, oh, I've already taken all this time off. Like all these things. I was so stressed about it. It was making me even more exhausted. And I just stopped and I paused and I was like, yes, but I also will be wasting my time if I stay here longer. If I stay for this final week, I'm not going to enjoy it. I'm going to just push myself maybe to a place that's going to be harder to recover from. So if you need to leave early, you're allowed to leave early. Maybe you've already gotten what you need out of this experience. It doesn't make you a coward.
为这张票付过钱了。哦，我已经请了这么长时间的假了。所有这些事情。我为此感到压力山大。这让我更加精疲力竭。我只是停下来，暂停了一下，然后我想，是的，但如果我在这里呆的时间更长，我也会浪费我的时间。如果我留下来过最后一周，我不会享受它。我只会把自己逼到一个可能更难恢复的地步。所以如果你需要提前离开，你是被允许提前离开的。也许你已经从这次经历中得到了你需要的东西。这并不意味着你是个懦夫。
It doesn't make you ungrateful. You're just doing what is best for you. And I think it was so strange, but I was so worried that of other people's opinions of me. but everyone who I talked to about this was like, oh, I totally get that. Like when you said you were traveling for two months, I was like, how is she going to cope? Like, I just think that no one really, no one thinks as harshly about your decisions as you do. So do what is best for you, but also take some time if you're feeling like really in the midst of it right now to just chill out. Just like take a rest day, find some small moments of joy.
这并不意味着你忘恩负义。你只是在做对你最有利的事。我觉得这太奇怪了，我太担心别人对我的看法了。但我谈到这件事的每个人都说，哦，我完全理解。就像当你说你要旅行两个月时，我在想，她会怎么应付？就像，我觉得没有人，真的没有人会像你自己那样严厉地看待你的决定。所以做对你最有利的事，但如果你现在真的深陷其中，也花点时间放松一下。就当放个假，寻找一些小小的快乐时刻。
Get away from the tourist areas. If you're in like a hostel, book like a nice hotel for a night. if you can afford it, it will make all the difference. And, like, put on your headphones and go for a walk. Like, just try and break out of, like, this space of negativity. Break out of the space of, like, guilt or of just, like, fatigue and feeling like you need to find the solution right now. Like, it's okay.
远离旅游区。如果你住在青年旅社，如果经济条件允许的话，订个好一点的酒店住一晚，这会有很大不同。而且，戴上耳机去散散步。试着打破这种负面情绪的空间。打破内疚或疲劳的空间，摆脱那种现在就需要找到解决办法的感觉。没关系的。
It's okay if your trip is, like, not going amazing. It's okay if, like, it isn't meeting your expectations. Like, you're still doing the thing. And in hindsight, I promise you, like, the experience will be important. and we'll teach you something and we'll give you something that you will take forward in your life. So I really hope that you enjoy this episode. I hope that you got something out of it. I feel like it was a lot more anecdotal.
如果你的旅行进展得不是那么顺利，也没关系。如果它没有达到你的预期，也没关系。你还在做这件事。事后看来，我向你保证，这段经历会很重要，会教给你一些东西，并会赋予你一些东西，带进你未来的生活中。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你从中有所收获。我觉得这一集更多的是个人经历的分享。
I just wanted to share my experience from, you know, what I've been doing. Travel is glamorized so much in our 20s, but I feel like we never talk about the other side of it. We never talk about how it's not always picture perfect. So hopefully this kind of pulled the veil back a little bit revealed more of the behind the facade of the picture perfect 20s that all of us expect. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to share it with someone who might enjoy it as well. Make sure that you give us a five-star reading on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are
我只是想分享我的经历，从我一直在做的事情来看。在20多岁的年纪，旅行被过度美化了，但我感觉我们从不谈论它的另一面。我们从不谈论它并不总是如画般完美。所以希望这稍微揭开了面纱，展现了我们所有人所期望的完美20岁背后的更多真实面貌。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时把它分享给可能也会喜欢它的人。确保在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或任何你正在收听的平台上
listening. It really helps this show to grow and meet, and meet, reach new people. And if you have an episode suggestion or you have feedback, you have thoughts on this episode, you disagree with anything. Please, follow me at that psychology. podcast and shoot me a DM. We would love to hear from you. We will be back later this week with another episode. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations
给我们一个五星好评。这真的有助于节目成长，并结识、结识、接触到新听众。如果你有节目建议或有反馈，对这一集有想法，有任何不同意的地方。请在 Instagram 上关注我 @thatpsychology.podcast 并给我发私信。我们很乐意听到你的声音。本周晚些时候我们将带着另一集回归。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Keer Games）带来的《艰难险阻》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关注黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，
that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability, that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全去进行，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难险阻》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian. Michael Manchin. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
奥恩斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动过两次手脚，对吗？我对测试动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）。迈克尔·曼钦（Michael Manchin）。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·奥恩斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客“2%”里。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and build. building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方上的 TWO Percent。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他绝不会就这样逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证纯人工。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。